are you worried about the investigation
prime minister
who coughed up for the flat sir he knows
the answer to that question
a question that's been shadowed in the
pm for days
how did he pay for the refurbishment of
the flat
did he as alleged by his former advisor
dominic cummins
explore the possibility of donors
secretly covering the cost
and if he did initially accept a loan
from donors via party hq was it properly
declared
now extraordinarily the electoral
commission
are opening an investigation saying
there are reasonable grounds to suspect
that an offense
or offenses may have occurred
that investigation now underway but the
fast cross-examination from this former
prosecutor
who initially paid for the redecoration
of his downing street flat he should
know that i paid for
uh dining street refurbishment
personally uh mr speaker normally when
people don't want to incriminate
themselves they go no comment
so i asked the prime minister again who
paid the initial
invoice i'm minister mr speaker i've
given him
the answer and the answer is i have i
have covered
the cost of course there's an electoral
commission uh invested investigating
this and i
i can tell him that i've conformed in
full with the code of conduct with
uh and minister's ministerial uh code
the pm rattled allegations of sleaze
bogging down
his premiership don't the british people
deserve a prime minister they can trust
and a government that isn't mired in
sleaze cronyism
and scandal that enough to push him over
the edge
this is a government that is getting on
with delivering on the people's
priorities including tougher sentences
mr speaker for serious sexual and
violent criminals which he opposed
and above all taking back control of our
country has allowed us to deliver the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe as he
well knows mr speaker
which would not have been possible which
would not have been possible if we'd
stayed
in the european medicines agency which
he
voted for this is a prime minister who's
faced his fair share of personal
and political scandal be it his
relationship with women his relationship
with the truth his use of loose language
but despite it all his easy charm and
bluster
has propelled him to the highest office
in the land
but now he faces the infamy of becoming
a sitting
prime minister whose activities are
under official investigation
by the authorities in that a line has
been crossed the pm says the public
don't much care
but some of his political allies worry
that
this time the scandal could stick
there are now three investigations into
the refurbishment of the prime
minister's flat
one's been undertaken by simon case the
head of the civil service
another by lord geit appointed today as
the new independent adviser on ministers
interests
but of the three it's this investigation
by the electoral commission
that has teeth and potentially big
consequences
beth rigby sky news westminster